THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> REPUBLICAN BRIAN KEMP HAS
DECLARED VICTORY, SAYS HE WILL
BEGIN HIS TRANSITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TODAY, BUT
DON'T FORGET, HIS OPPONENT,
STACEY ABRAMS, SHE IS NOT
CONCEDING YET.
>> DeSANTIS HAS DECLARED
VICTORY, GILLUM HAS CONCEDED,
BUT HE HAS TWEETED THAT HE WANTS
EVERY VOTE TO COUNT.
>> BILL NELSON HAS BROUGHT IN A
HIGH-POWERED DEMOCRATIC LAWYER
FROM WASHINGTON, D.C., TO
OVERSEE THIS RECOUNT.
>> Laura: WHILE, ENCLOSED AND
CONTENTIOUS RACE TO
DEMOCRATS MORE SO THAN
REPUBLICANS SEEM TO HAVE A
PROBLEM CONCEDING DEFEAT.
IT CAN'T BE THAT THE OTHER GUY
WON FAIR AND SQUARE, IT HAS TO
BE THAT EITHER THE ELECTION
SYSTEM BROKE DOWN OR SOME
MYSTERY BOATS ARE HIDING
SOMEWHERE OR THE ENTIRE PROCESS
MUST BE TAINTED.
THEN THERE IS THE OTHER WAY TO
EXPLAIN A TOUGH LOSS, WHILE, THE
VOTERS MUST BE RACIST.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S INSTINCTS WERE
VALIDATED IN BIG SECTIONS OF THE
COUNTRY.
THE INCITEMENT STRATEGY, THE
RACIAL DEMAGOGUERY, IT WORKED.
TRUMP'S REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
GETTING INCREASINGLY OLDER,
INCREASINGLY WIDER, INCREASINGLY
RURAL.
>> THE OTHER THING THAT COULD BE
HAPPENING IN FLORIDA IS THE
BRADLEY EFFECT, WHICH ONCE
AFFECTED -- LOWERED THE ELECTION
DATE VOTE TOTALS OF BLACK VOTER
VOTERS.
HOLE WOULD SHOW THAT BRADLEY
WOULD WIN, AND ON ELECTION DAY,
HE WOULD LOSE.
>> Laura: EVEN AFTER DEMOCRATS
FLIP TO THE HOUSE AND MANY
MINORITY CANDIDATES WON FROM
COAST-TO-COAST, WHAT IS THE
RESULT IN THE FLORIDA'S
GOVERNOR'S RACE AND GEORGIA
ROLLED IN, ADAM SORT OF THE
ATLANTIC PUBLISHED THIS PIECE
TITLED "AMERICA'S PROBLEM ISN'T
TRIBALISM, IT IS RACISM."
WRITING, "IF REPUBLICANS RAN ON
THEIR POLICY AGENDA ALONE, THEY
WOULD BE AT A DISADVANTAGE.
SO THEY TURN TO A DESTRUCTIVE
POLITICS OF WHITE IDENTITY, ONE
THAT SEEKS THE PATH OF POWER BY
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY AMONG
RACIAL AND SECTARIAN LINES.
THEY PORTRAY THE NATION AS THE
BIRTHRIGHT OF WHITE,
HETEROSEXUAL CHRISTIANS."
YEAH, ADAM, THAT IS WHAT THOSE
POLICIES THAT LED TO RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR LATINOS AND
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WERE ALL
ABOUT, STOKING ETHNIC FEARS.
THAT IS ABSURD.
THE MOST DESPICABLE USE OF
RACISM IN THE MIDTERM CAME FROM
THE TRUMP HATERS AND SOME
DEMOCRATS.
>> I'M NOT CALLING
MR. DeSANTIS A RACIST, I AM
SUBLEASING THE RACISTS BELIEVE
HE IS A RACIST.
>> SIGN ME UP IN THE CATEGORY OF
PEOPLE WHO THINK HE IS RACIST.
HE HAS SAID SO MANY RACIST
THINGS.
HE IS A RACIST PIG!
>> MAKING OVERTLY BIGOTED,
RACIST STATEMENTS, ATTACKING
DOWN PEOPLE, ATTACKING BLACK
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WHEN BIZARRE AND
SUSPICIOUS RACIST ROLL CALLS
WERE REPORTED IN FLORIDA,
REMEMBER REPUBLICANS, INCLUDING
DeSANTIS AND RICK SCOTT,
IMMEDIATELY AND VOCIFEROUSLY
DENOUNCE THEM, AS THEY SHOW IT.
BACK IN 2016, THE MEDIA TRIED TO
PAINT TRUMP AS THEY WANT --
REMEMBER, HE WASN'T GOING TO BE
ACCEPTING ANY OF THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION.
>> ARE YOU SAYING YOU ARE NOT
PREPARED NOW --
>> I WILL TELL YOU AT THE TIME,
I WILL KEEP YOU IN SUSPENSE.
>> Laura: HILLARY RESPONDED TO
THAT LIKE THIS.
>> THAT IS HORRIFYING.
EVERY TIME DONALD THINKS THAT
THINGS ARE NOT GOING IN HIS
DIRECTION, HE CLAIMS WHATEVER IT
IS IS RIGGED AGAINST HIM.
THAT IS NOT THE WAY OUR
DEMOCRACY WORKS.
HE IS DENIGRATING, HE IS TALKING
DOWN OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: "TALKING DOWN OUR
DEMOCRACY" BEAR THE MEDIA ECHOED
HILLARY, OUTRAGED THAT TRUMP
WOULD EVER CHALLENGE LEGITIMACY
OF AN ELECTION WON FAIR AND
SQUARE.
BUT ALL OF THEIR FULL MORAL
OUTRAGE WAS EXPOSED WHEN IT WHEN
TRUMP ACTUALLY WON IN 2016.
A SUDDENLY COME OUR SACROSANCT
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY -- IT
WASN'T SO SACROSANCT AFTER ALL.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I RISE TODAY
TO DISCUSS LEGISLATION I
INTRODUCED TO ELIMINATE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND ENSURE THE
CANDIDATE WHO WINS THE MOST
VOTES WILL BE ELECTED PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: THE HECK WITH THE
WAY THE FRAMERS OF THE SET IT
UP, LET'S DISPENSE WITH IT SINCE
WE LOST.
OF COURSE THEY HAVE THEIR
HANGUPS AROUND LEGITIMACY, OBAMA
IS BIRTH CERTIFICATE, WHICH
>> Laura: HIMSELF FOCUSED ON.
BUT ALL MOST CIRCLE YEARS INTO
THE TRUMP A ADMINISTRATION, MANY
OF THE DIEHARDS -- AFTER ALL,
THEY ARE CALLED THE
RESISTANCE -- STILL DO NOT
ACCEPT THE RESULTS.
>> I BELIEVE IN TRYING TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE -- IT IS GOING TO BE
HARD, IT IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
I DON'T SEE THIS PRESIDENT-ELECT
AS A LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> MY PERSONAL VIEW IS THAT IT
WAS NOT AN    AN A LEGITIMATE EE
WAS NOT AN    AN A LEGITIMATE ET
WAS NOT AN    AN A LEGITIMATE EO
WAS NOT AN    AN A LEGITIMATE E
ELECTION.
>> I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS LEGITIMACY,
AND WE DON'T HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
CONTESTING THAT IN OUR SYSTEM.
>> Laura: NO WONDER PEOPLE ARE
LOSING FAITH IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM.
LISTEN TO THOSE PEOPLE.
ACCORDING TO AN AXIOS SURVEY,
JUST 51 PERCENT OF AMERICANS
SAID THEY HAVE FAITH IN THE
COUNTRIES DEMOCRACY.
A WHOPPING 37 PERCENT, MORE THAN
A THIRD, SAY THEY HAVE LOST
FAITH IN IT.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS REALLY
DISTRESSING FOR AMERICA'S FUTUR
FUTURE.
IF THE PEOPLE DECIDE THE SYSTEM
IS ROTTEN, THEY ARE REALLY
SAYING THE COUNTRY IS ROTTEN.
AND SOON THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SAYING IT ISN'T WORTH PROTECTING
ANYMORE AT ALL.
BUT LET'S HOPE THAT WE CAN TURN
THIS DYNAMIC AROUND, THERE IS SO
MUCH CRAZINESS OUT THERE.
THIS MEANS THAT BOTH PARTIES
NEED TO DO BETTER AT FOCUSING ON
ISSUES, THE ISSUES THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CARE ABOUT, INSTEAD OF
JUST A PERPETUAL GRIEVANCE,
POLITICS, IT IS GETTING OLD.
LOOK, SOME RECOUNTS ARE
MANDATED, AND THEY ARE IN
FLORIDA, AND IF THE MARGINS ARE
CLOSE ENOUGH, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS, THEY SHOULD BOTH
ENSURE THAT ANY RECOUNT IS DONE
FAIRLY, NO CREATING BALLOTS
WHERE NONE EXISTED.
I HAVE TO SAY, IT WOULD HARDLY
REASSURING TO LEARN TODAY THAT
IN FLORIDA MOST POPULOUS COUNTY,
BROWARD, THE ELECTIONS OF CHEAP
THERE IS A DEMOCRAT NAMED IT
BRENDA SNIPES BRENDA WAS FOUND
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FD
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FR
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FL
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FW
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FF
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FR
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FD
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FS
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FR
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FY
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FN
GUILTY OF VIOLATING STATE AND FG
BALLOTS IN THE 2016
CONGRESSIONAL RACE WHEN THOSE
BALLOTS WHERE, AT THE TIME,
SUBJECT TO A LAWSUIT.
AND BREAKING IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF HOURS, WE HAD A LAWSUIT FILED
BY GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT AGAINST
BROWARD AND PALM BEACH COUNTY.
HE IS GOING ON THE OFFENSIVE,
RIGHTFULLY, AGAINST THIS ENTIRE
SHODDY PRACTICE.
REPUBLICAN LAWYERS, YOU BETTER
MAKE SURE THAT DEMOCRATS DO NOT
START TORCHING ABSENTEE BALLOTS
IN DUMPSTERS IN BOCA, OR FINDING
OTHER BALLOTS OTHER PLACES.
LET'S ALL JUST REMEMBER THAT
WHILE LOSING IS NEVER FUN, AND
WE REMEMBER OUR LOSSES, BELIEVE
ME -- REMEMBER '92, '96, 2006
DURING THE BUSH MIDTERMS, 2008,
2012, IT IS NEVER FUN.